we begin so much to cover including
more from my exclusive interview with
president trump that we have not been
able to air yet
and also tonight new details in the
police involved shooting
of mikaya bryant and coming up we'll
show you what triggered the 911 call in
the first place
and we have new footage of violent riots
across the country
even tonight it's now obvious that many
on the left believe
that america is an evil racist country
the only way to fix it
i guess burned the entire system to the
ground greatest country god gave man
our founders and favors they gave us
something a path to right wrongs and
correct injustices and we have a history
of doing so
that is ignored now of course this
egregious lie has been spoon-fed
to the masses by democrats and the media
mob for decades
i tell you every two years every four
years it's a democratic party playbook
and now any opposition to the democrats
radical socialist
power grab now they're calling that
racist for example
democrats are now attempting to make
washington d.c
the 51st state they are doing this
because nearly 100 percent
of washington residents are democrats
if dc becomes a state democrats would
pick up two new senate seats
pretty much in perpetuity that's what
they believe and it's likely true
the only problem is d.c statehood is
barred by this
document called oh that's right the
constitution
the framers or founders they wanted to
limit the power
of our nation's capital according to
democrats anyone who opposes d.c
statehood is now a racist take a look
i have had enough of my colleagues
racist insinuations that somehow the
people of washington d.c are incapable
or
even unworthy of our democracy
one senate republican said that d.c
wouldn't be a quote
well-rounded working-class state
i had no idea there were so many
syllables in the word white
one of my house republican colleagues
said that d.c shouldn't be a state
because the district
doesn't have a landfill my goodness
with all the racist trash my colleagues
have brought to this debate
i can see why they're worried about
having a place to put it
of course the media mob press wing of
the democratic party is backing up these
idiotic claims now the washington post
headline reads quote
the battle against d.c statehood is
rooted in
anti-black racism that is real
nbc news reporting that the opposition
of the democrats plan is quote part
of an ugly effort to disenfranchise
black and brown people
new york magazine accusing congressman
steve scalise
of being an ignorant racist for arguing
against d.c
statehood and that's not all apparently
now the legislative filibuster is also
suddenly racist
remember in 2019 2020 president trump
was in office
republicans controlled the senate guess
what those democrats used
by their definition that racist
filibuster 270 times
now democrats they have control the
filibuster now it's magically become
a tool of oppression and bigotry and
racism
senator elizabeth warren you know the
same senator that faked her ethnicity
for years
said the filibuster has deep roots in
racism
congresswoman ocasio-cortez
congresswoman omar
blasting the filibuster for its ties to
white supremacy
dick durbin well he had this to say
about the
filibuster's evil history take a look
there was a statement made by senator
mcconnell the republican leader
yesterday which is nothing short of
amazing
at a press conference he said of the
filibuster and i quote
it has no racial history at all none
amazing that he would say that certainly
senator mcconnell who was working in the
senate at that time as an
intern if i'm not mistaken must remember
the filibuster being used against a
civil rights bill
and to say that the filibuster has no
racial history at all
none is to ignore the obvious
same civil rights act and voting rights
act 6465
that joe biden's partner the former
klansmen
tried to stop integration of schools oh
interesting
this is not what the democrats were
saying when republicans had control
you might want to take a trip down
memory lane let's just go back oh a
whopping one year ago
take a look what about that nuclear
option doing away with the filibuster
well i can tell you that would be the
end of the senate as it was originally
devised and created going back to our
founding fathers i said
let's not do the supreme court we should
have 60 votes
which we still do because we should get
bipartisan support
the point is we still left the 60 votes
in place right for the supreme court
and mitch mcconnell changed that i would
prefer to bring it back
well how much can change in a few months
well apparently because according to
democrats now the filibuster that they
use
270 times is racist also opposition to
d.c
statehood that's racist too and don't
forget
the new georgia voting bill that
requires voter id
just like delaware and expands early
voting in-person voting to 17 days
well that's racist as well joe biden
referred to it numerous times as jim
crow 2.0
but when you look at joe biden's home
state or as
joe referred to it as his state being
the slave state
it has far more restrictive voting laws
than georgia
and joe has represented delaware what i
think it's about
500 years now never lifted a finger
in over 50 years to bring reform
openness
and greater accessibility to the people
of delaware as it relates to voting
so by joe's definition he's a racist
and he supports jim crow 2.0 and has his
entire
long boring dull political career
and of course securing the southern
border that's also racist
congresswoman omar said that the border
wall was a
monument to racism naturally climate
change
also racist so if you pose the insane
socialist green new deal
that pretends to fight climate change
that's really about redistribution and
socialism
you're also a racist take a look the
climate crisis
is a crisis born of injustice
and it is a crisis born of the pursuit
of profit at
any and all human and ecological costs
which means that we must recognize in
legislation
that the trampling of indigenous rights
is a cause of climate change
the the trampling of racial justice is a
cause of climate
change because we are allowing people
and we are allowing ourselves
to make sure that we are allowing folks
to deny ourselves human rights
and deny people the right to health care
the right to housing and education
so make no mistake everything democrats
disagree with
is racist the founding fathers the
constitution
first amendment second amendment
christopher columbus
law enforcement now last night in new
york city blm rioters
well they combined two of their favorite
villains and one
demonstration they vandalized a monument
in columbus circle by spray painting it
with anti-police slogans
and meanwhile columbus ohio where
fifteen-year-old
makia bryant attempted to stab an
unarmed girl in the chest pinned to a
car
before getting shot by a responding
officer
blm activists there were chanting quote
you shoot us
we shoot you watch this
tonight based on all of the evidence
that we have
makia bryant she was shot because she
was less than a fraction of a second
away from
stabbing and likely killing a young
unarmed girl with a knight pinned
against the car fox news
has learned that police were called to
the scene because of an altercation that
had erupted
between bryant and the other girl over
the cleanliness of the house
is it tragic yes sad yes every life
matters
but when officers arrived makia knife in
hand
loaded screamed i'm going to stab you
bleep then pinned an unknown girl to the
car
loaded back the blade was ready to
thrust that blade
and strike at either the neck the chest
could have killed her but facts just
don't seem to matter to the left their
narrative is
is the most important thing lebron james
doxing the police officer
tweeting out his photo along with a
threatening message
to 50 million followers by the way i
wonder if a conservative did it
would at jack at twitter cancel their
account
forever james put an officer's life at
risk
and last night president trump responded
writing quote
lebron james racist rants are divisive
they're nasty they're insulting and
they're demeaning
he may be a great basketball player but
he is doing
nothing to bring our country together
and meanwhile just a few days ago
congresswoman maxine waters
called for violent confrontations on the
streets
what happened to the party of compassion
what happened to all the unity joe
promised us
but don't worry maxine waters now claims
that she's totally non-violent
and never calls for violence on the
radical left
up is down down is up facts no longer
matter
truth doesn't matter uh don't believe me
think about the russia hoax and the
dirty dossier
and he uh the fisa applications that spy
on a president
maybe that's why people who claim to
care so deeply about racism
and minorities and about poverty well
they've displayed a sign
with special instructions for quote any
white people
who visit the george floyd memorial
in minnesota hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else